bonjour aujourd'hui à vendredi 6
novembre nouvelle édition de votre
journal de fin de semaine voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer le conseil réunissant les
agents et les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines agitée jeudi soir puisque les
agents ont souhaité exprimer leurs
désaccords notamment sur la nouvelle
organisation horaire qui les concernera
en janvier explications réactions les
élus des départements de la grande
couronne se réunissent au sein d'une
association afin de peser dans le débat
du grand paris se sentent exclus de ce
projet de métropole ils veulent avancer
leurs propres propositions entretien
vous le voyez avec pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines à suivre et comme chaque
vendredi retour sur les principaux
sujets que nous avons développé cette
semaine de la lutte contre le
harcèlement à l'école à l'opération zéro
fraude lancées par la sncf
plus d'une centaine d'agents présents
donc jeudi soir pour accueillir les élus
participant au conseil communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines une
mobilisation pour dénoncer les nouvelles
mesures autour du temps de travail qui
devrait rentrer en application au 1er
janvier 2016
depuis 45 ans nous agents de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines avons bâti et développer ce
territoire c'est par notre travail sous
la conduite des élus que nous gérons la
chose commune aujourd'hui 45 ans de bons
et loyaux services ont été balayés en
trois semaines c'est avant tout une
affaire de manque de considération d'une
centaine d'agents présents jeudi soir
avant l'ouverture du conseil
communautaire de saint quentin en
yvelines menée par une intersyndicale
cgt cfdt il entendait s'opposer à la
suppression de 13 jours de congé et à
l'augmentation de leur temps de travail
des ajustements néanmoins demandé suite
aux résultats d'audit interne qui
révélait des avantages jugés illégaux
audit qui pointe par ailleurs des
protocoles qui seraient jusqu'à présent
trop favorable aux agents il y a eu des
acquis sociaux
on était assez ancien qui date des
années fin des années soixante dix
années 80 qui ont été établies pour les
agents des territoires eu de la casse
qui on estime avoir faire un bon travail
ce n'était qu'une juste récompense du
travail accompli sur le territoire et là
où c'est un bar d'heure c'est qu'on
entend partout dans la presse etc
le fonctionnaire bashing qui on va dire
quelque chose de très à la mode
on est toujours en train de stigmatiser
les fonctionnaires une délégation a été
reçue par le président michel laugier si
ce dernier a répété ne pas être contre
les discussions il entend que les
ajustements se fasse rapidement
ce que j'ai vu quand je suis arrivé dans
cette agglomération c'est que il ya un
temps de travail qui doit être respecté
et aujourd'hui nous en sommes loin
donc j'ai commencé à travailler avec eux
j'ai ouvert les négociations dont nous
sommes en cours de dialogue moi
aujourd'hui j'ai confiance dans les
collaborateurs de la communauté d'agglo
je les fréquente depuis un certain temps
beaucoup plus depuis que je suis
président donc je sais très bien que je
peux compter sur des agents de grande
qualité
là j'attends aussi qu'ils fassent preuve
aussi de propositions des
contre-propositions des représentants du
personnel qui seront présentés lors
d'une réunion programmée le 10 novembre
une majorité des 650 agents de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ont malgré tout décidé de
maintenir la pression en déposant un
préavis de grève au vendredi prochain
alors que la métropole du grand paris
est en train de prendre forme les
départements franciliens ont décidé à
ceux qui sont les plus éloignés de la
capitale de faire entendre leur voix le
val d'oise de l'essonne la
seine-et-marne et les yvelines réunis au
sein d'une association lancement
officiel le lancement officiel s'est
déroulée hier écouter tout d'abord le
président de l'essonne nous estimons que
la région doit marcher sur deux jambes
il y à la métropole du grand paris qui
est constituée à partir du 1er janvier
nous le regrettons parce que nous
estimons que la métropole c'est la
région ile de france mais c'est un fait
désormais et donc nous estimons que la
région ne peut pas être dans un face à
face uniquement avec la métropole et
qu'elle a besoin de marcher sur deux
jambes et que les départements de grande
couronne devait s'organiser au travers
de cette association pour défendre les
intérêts des habitants et à l'occasion
de cette annonce sur la création d'une
association entre les différents
départements de la grande couronne nous
avons rencontré pierre bédier c'est le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines il ne le parle de l'avenir de
ce département justement pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines on quitte le département pour
les sols cette fois ci pour évoquer la
création de cette association grande
couronne capital et vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est une contrainte vous êtes
obligés de créer cette association
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce qu'on est les
grandes oubliées les grandes oubliées de
la réforme du grand paris le grand paris
c'est une très belle idée
nous sommes tous d'accord parce qu on
est patriote ou on est français on veut
que la france réussisse pour réussir la
france a besoin d'avoir une locomotive
économique qui s'appelle la métropole du
grand paris qui va être compétitive face
aux anglais du grand londres
face aux américains de new york de la
silicon valley face aux chinois de
shanghai ocs japonais tokyo donc on a
besoin du grand paris mais ce grand
paris nous exclut ce grand paris on l'a
arrêté à paris et la petite couronne ce
qui n'a pas de sens le grand paris ça va
être la région parisienne et dans cette
région parisienne il ya quatre
départements qui se sont réunis ici mon
ami jean jacques barbot pour la
seine-et-marne
mon ami arnaud bazin pour le val d'oise
mon ami françois durovray pour l'essonne
et moi-même ses six millions d'habitants
c'est la moitié de la population la
région parisienne et qui dit on doit pas
être les oubliés parce que vous avez
besoin de nous si on n'a pas de
transport efficace les gens qui passent
deux heures aller au boulot vous croyez
que quand ils arrivent au boulot ils
sont en forme et on voudrait que
l'économie francilienne donc l'économie
française soit plus compétitif sans s'en
donner les moyens
c'est ça qu'on veut changer mais quand
vous dites seuls les grands départements
de la grande couronne sont les grands
oubliés justement ça veut dire quoi
concrètement que les transports qui sont
prévues ne sont pas adaptés que les
dotations prévues ne sont pas
suffisantes
concrètement ça signifie quoi ça veut
dire deux choses premièrement dans la
carte du grand paris on n'est pas dedans
on est la carte du grand paris c'est
paris la seine-saint-denis le
val-de-marne les hauts-de-seine c'est à
dire la partie danse laurens ton ça
n'occupe pas alors qu'on a besoin de
nous et puis on a des habitants on
existe quand même on n'est ni des
provinciaux ni des grands parisien on
est on est rien aujourd'hui
et deuxièmement quand vous regardez les
différentes dépenses vous voyez bien que
la grande couronne est largement oubliée
en particulier dans notre réunion de
travail on le voyait à quel point dans
le domaine universitaire au contrat de
plan entre l'état et la région ben on
oublie la grande couronne comme s'il y
avait pas d'étudiants en grande couronne
comme si y'avait pas de cerveau en
grande couronne parler de cette réunion
de travail de ces réunions travaille
justement concrètement votre association
va fonctionner comment c'est une
association totalement informelle
j'insiste bien sur le fait qu'elle ne
coûtera pas un sou au contribuable à un
moment où le le gouvernement socialiste
nous passe à la paille à la paille de
fer
donc on a pu en rond il n'est pas
question de partir dans dépenses
somptuaires c'est donc une association
informelle mais une association qui veut
peser dans le débat politique
qui veut dire deux choses qui veut dire
d'abord eh bien oui nous voulons être
dans la métropole du grand paris pour
que le grand paris soit compétitif pour
que la france soit plus compétitif nous
voulons construire et non pas exclure et
puis d'autre part dans cette grande
couronne nous avons six millions
d'habitants
la moitié des habitants de la région
parisienne on ne peut pas les ignorer
symboliquement c'est aussi important à
un mois du scrutin des régionales c'est
aussi l'occasion de se faire entendre et
de faire pression mais de se rappeler au
bon souvenir des différents candidats
peu importe qui sera ensuite élu
président alors d'abord personne
n'ignore que nous sommes tous les quatre
d'une majorité de la droite et du centre
et que dans tous soutenir valérie
pécresse et que nous préférons qu'elle
soit présente deux régions mais de toute
façon
valérie pécresse ou quel que soit le
futur président de région il nous
entendra encore parce que c'est le
gouvernement qui s'est planté
ce gouvernement a fait un grand paris
étriqué son grand paris c'est un petit
pari que nous on veut un grand paris qui
sont un grand paris pour la france parce
que la france a besoin de la région
parisienne la région parisienne
aujourd'hui c'est 30% de la production
de la richesse avec les évolutions
économiques en cours autour de la
révolution numérique
demain ça sera 35% et peut-être 40% et
ça doit englober toute la région
parisienne aux trans une erreur
stratégique dont la france fera souffrir
pendant des décennies je vous en donne
un exemple ici on est à côté du plateau
de versailles saclay où doit être
constitué le grand cluster de
l'intelligence française
il est où il en petite couronne en
grande couronne hymne et en grande
couronne c'est à dire qu'on investit des
milliards dans un endroit dont on finit
par l'oublier
géographiquement c'est stupide et c'est
ça que nous combattons et c'est vrai que
venir à evry dans la ville de monsieur
valls pour montrer à quel point son
gouvernement est incohérent c'est un
petit pied de nez dont nous nous privons
pas comparer aujourd'hui c'est un pari
raté justement cette métropole cette
idée de faire une grande métropole s'en
prend le chemin ils ont fait tapis et je
pense que
les gouvernants vont finir un c'est
parce qu'ils se sont plantés une toute
dernière question puisqu'il est question
éventuellement d'un rapprochement aussi
avec le département des hauts-de-seine
patrick devedjian votre homologue qui
évoquait la création d'un établissement
public par exemple c'est pas en
contradiction aujourd'hui avec
l'association que vous montez avec les
autres les autres départements pardon de
la grande couronne
c'est le même principe avec une
intensité différente puisque nous avons
une frontière et une proximité
économique très forte avec le
département des hauts-de-seine le
département des hauts-de-seine c'est le
premier bassin d'emploi pardon d'emploi
des yvelinois et donc
il ya une plus grande intensité et le
département des hauts-de-seine pour le
coup n'a absolument pas de territoire
c'est tout petit le département des
hauts-de-seine et dompter 2200
kilomètres carrés du département des
yvelines sont très naturellement le la
zone d'expansion de l'économie alto
séquanaise est donc cette association
que nous souhaitons très étroites de
plus en plus étroite et pour lequel on
fera effectivement dans quelques mois
quelques je pense innovation forte et
bien cette association
elle est dans la même logique faire du
développement économique c'est quoi le
problème de la france aujourd'hui c'est
le chômage
tout le reste c'est de la littérature
alors je sais qu'il est de bon ton à
gauche de rappeler la phrase de monsieur
vita on a tout essayé contre le chômage
non il ya juste un truc qu'on n'a pas
essayé s'est créé de la richesse c'est
arrêter de penser que les entrepreneurs
ne sont que des poutres qui viennent sur
le dos des pauvres gens grossirait
prospérer pas du tout on a besoin
d'entreprises
on a besoin de recherche on a besoin de
développement économique on a besoin de
création de richesses tout simplement
pour pouvoir ensuite partager cette
richesse pour les plus modestes d'entre
eux une toute dernière question le
rapprochement avec les hauts-de-seine
pour 2016 c'est d'actualité toujours
toujours puisque jamais qui seront
faites tout à fait vous avez un
département des yvelines qui est très
allants à la fois comme départements de
grande couronne à la fois comme
département de très grande proximité
j'ai envie de dire presque de proximité
génétique on a le même adn avec les
hauts-de-seine
qu'ils s'agissent de notre économie
qu'il s'agisse de notre territoire de
notre géographie on à la seine en
partage enfin on partage énormément de
choses donc oui le département des
yvelines est très allants dans ces deux
directions qui ne sont absolument pas
contradictoire au contraire d'une façon
encore une fois de vouloir entraîner de
la dynamique de création de richesse en
tout cas j'ai des convictions je
souhaitais les partager avec tous les
yvelinois parce que tout ce que nous
faisons le département des yvelines est
au service des yvelinois qu'il s'agisse
de la création de richesse qu'il s'agit
de la solidarité qui ne peut
naturellement s'exercer que si on a de
l'argent et donc si on a fait cette
création de richesses initial c'est en
tout cas le sens de mon action politique
le sens de l'action politique de la
majorité départementale
merci beaucoup pierre bédier merci
comme chaque vendredi à présent retour
sur une semaine d'actualité locale voici
donc le zapping de l'info le montage est
signée xavier gère à présent un point
sur la transat jacques vabre vous le
savez le skipper versailles et tanguy de
lamotte participe actuellement à la
compétition le navigateur est parti avec
sa coéquipière samantha davies le
dimanche 25 octobre du port du havre à
bord de son imoca initiative coeur
victime d'une avarie vendredi dernier le
skipper a réussi à réparer son bateau
ils pointent actuellement à la 5e place
du classement
évolution des comportements d'achat et à
des commerces de proximité ou encore
impact des centres commerciaux la cci
versailles a révélé ce matin une grande
enquête plus ripoll sur le commerce dans
notre département
une attractivité due notamment aux
centres commerciaux la zone de plaisir
les clés est la grande gagnante de cette
enquête c'est le premier pôle commercial
du département 8 heures du matin gare de
saint quentin en yvelines 30 contrôleurs
et 10 agents de la sécurité de la sncf
sont déployés pour l'opération zéro
fraude à saint-quentin-en-yvelines 27
mille voyageurs empruntent chaque jour
la gare des usagers qui ne comprennent
pas tous l'utilité de ces contrôles
comme par hasard
aujourd'hui je me regardant dans l'aude
veste en fait j'ai mis la mauvaise reste
je dois payer 50 euros
mais si je présente ma carte voilà au
service clientèle ça va j'ai remboursé
longueur et nous vous en parlions hier
lé enquête sur la mort du jeune moussa
victime d'un tir dans une fusillade à
trappes le 1er mai dernier progresse
selon nos confrères du parisien
un second suspect âgé de 30 ans a été
arrêté cet homme serait l'oncle du
premier homme interpellé hier il s'est
spontanément présenté à la brigade
criminelle de versailles avant de
rejoindre son neveu en garde à vue
lutter à travers la plume c'est toute
l'ambition des jeunes autour de cette
table rédacteur pour le très petit blog
il souhaite tordre le cou aux clichés
sur les banlieues véhiculée selon eux
par les médias et un master de
littérature générale et comparée et
banquets je trouve que ça colle bien
écrire dans les blogs et surtout écrire
pour ma ville pour valoriser ma vive et
toujours attraper les gardiens
d'immeubles et locataires du square
jules védrines sont en colère depuis
plusieurs mois selon leurs dires un
trafic de stupéfiants s'est installé
dans le quartier portes serrures cave
loges sont dégradées des squats sont
également installées dans les parties
communes
c'est important qu'ils aient des
journées comme ça parce qu'on est devant
on a vraiment l'impression d'un choc
générationnel entre ces générations sur
surtout sur les questions du numérique
on a beaucoup parlé des questions du
numérique parce que c'est surtout là que
se fait le harcèlement aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup discuté notre utilisation des
réseaux sociaux
là on vient de faire un test sur notre
réputation donc la réputation qu'on a
sur le web aujourd'hui utilisée quand
même pas les employeurs le harcèlement
concernerait environ 700 mille élèves
chaque année une équipe nationale
pourrait prendre ses quartiers à
versailles pour l'euro de football 2016
l'uefa organisatrice du tournoi a retenu
la cité royale pour accueillir une
sélection juin prochain la commune
yvelinoise est une habituée des grandes
compétitions
l'étudiant 98 surtout la coupe du monde
une équipe quitter la hollande
on a fait en accueillir l'angleterre
pour le rugby pour la coupe du monde
aussi de 2017
et en parlant de rôles affaire tombe mal
ajustement sept mois de l'événement qui
a réuni benzema a été déféré devant la
justice dans la sphère du chantage à la
sextape de mathieu valbuena l'attaquant
du real de madrid a été placé hier en
garde à vue dans les locaux de la police
judiciaire de versailles
il aurait reconnu être intervenu dans le
chantage fait à mathieu valbuena ce que
son avocat des mots selon le procureur
il a été mise en examen pour complicité
et tentative de chantage
l'international français est placé sous
contrôle judiciaire avec l'interdiction
d'entrer en contact de quelques façons
ce soit avec la victime et les autres
mises en examen
chaque vendredi nous vous proposons
également une nouvelle séquence dans ce
journal regard de jeunes sur l'actualité
c'est en partenariat avec le collège les
soldes guyancourt la rubrique est
préparée par william elle deuxième
épisode à découvrir dès à présent
bonjour ma peine à elle donc j'ai dix
ans ouais et je suis un sixième je vais
vous parler du harcèlement ou pas en
fait c'est des personnes qui
quitteraient tu vraiment pas vraiment
très très très très mal à personne qu'il
insulte qui qui même des fois la suivent
même en dehors des écoles des fois donc
voilà et même des fois à cause de ça il
ya des gens qui se suicident très
souvent à des fois il ya des gens qui
pleurent à cause de ça donc voilà et des
fois il y en a qui se disent oui j'ai
pas une très belle pis voilà donc c'est
pas très joli comme ça moi c'était pas
trop de drc le monde moi mais en ce1 pas
exemple le comme une famille c'est
kerchouche on m'appelle neil kerchouche
la cartouche moi ça me faisait parler je
peux aller carrément tout le temps c'est
vrai j'avais tout a dit khaled mechaal a
mis à recommencer toujours ça a évolué
pas quoi mais mano et batum ont grandi
prend ses responsabilités a justement la
sauce et d'en parler tout minogue et pas
d'en parler essayer des personnes vous
harcèle vous embête
n'hésitez pas à le dire aux autres ou
vos amis voilà pour un gala pour lui les
problèmes
bonjour je m'appelle tony j'ai 15 ans je
suis actuellement un troisième au
collège et sol et aujourd'hui je vous
parlais de la commauté la coop 21 c'est
une conférence sur le climat qui se
déroulera à paris dans novembre et en
décembre pour a pour but de trouver des
solutions sur le développement durable
et l'environnement 195 pays vont y
participer et moi bah si de faire des
trouver des solutions pour contre la
pollution contre leur chemin plein et
climatique
parce que si on augmente d'ici 2030 de 3
degrés ça serait complètement immersive
on pourra plus rien faire on ne pourra
pas revenir en arrière
les festayres va changer en fait la
planète a va s'habituer plus que nous à
la chaleur qu'on a créés et puis bah si
la farq boîte mais on va se retrouver
avec des chaleurs en été en hiver mais
il sera poussé les protège du froid
il aura la nage une grotte plus chauds
ainsi suite on est et sera peut-être
plus chaud plus sec et dans le combat on
aura du mal à trouver des plantations 17
repas des choses comme ça pour manger et
quand je vois tous les déchets qui
traînent dehors les gens qui font pas
attention qui est un mégot par terre
dans le décret ce défunt et de la masse
et pourrait mener à la poubelle je
trouve ça assez assez dommage que il
fasse pas mon attention à la fenêtre qui
nous est très cher parce que c'est là
c'est la seule planète pour l'instant on
a trouvé pour abriter la vie
bayal tri sélectif mais ça serait
chouette que tout le monde s'y met tout
cela ensemble parce que sinon moi je
fais d'accord ça fait quelque chose mais
que tout le monde le fasse ça ferait
énormément de bien la planète ça
soulagera un petit peu peut-être et ça
nous promet ça nous permettra peut-être
de a conservé un peu plus de temps un
regard de jeunes sur l'actualité tous
les vendredis retrouvez donc dans ce
journal un mot de la programmation pour
ce week-end de nos confrères de radio
sensations à présent nicolas
kirillovitch reçoit pour son hebdo
politique dimanche à 18 heures eva joly
eurodéputée europe écologie d'île de
france il sera bien sûr question de
cette coop 21 sommet mondial qui se
tiendra à paris dans quelques semaines
mais elle a aussi donné son point de vue
sur d'autres sujets écouter cet extrait
d'après un sondage au doxa près d'un
français sur deux serait désormais prêt
à une augmentation de l'âge de la du
départ à la retraite
faut-il s'y résoudre ou existe-t-il une
alternative selon vous mâche pense qu
est ce qui est bien c'est vraiment la
liberté
c'est de ne pas avoir un couperet c'est
de ne pas être obligé de partir à la
retraite parce que ça aussi c'est un
problème pour beaucoup de gens on
emballe passion souvent navire s'empare
de l'un vers ce marché à mon âge j'ai
beaucoup d'amis pour qui ça c'est un
drame est un système beaucoup plus
souple comme on l'a comment le pratiquer
en norvège où on peut travailler jusqu'à
75 si on le veut et on gagne on peut
construire sa retraite jusqu'à 75 ans
c'est aussi pour beaucoup vécu comme man
comme al'avantage quelque chose qui qui
permet de vivre plus pleinement plus
longtemps mais je ne dis pas que je
souhaite le recul de l'âge de la
retraite je dis que je souhaite la
liberté la suite à écouter sur radio
sensations dimanche on a retrouvé sur le
compte youtube de la station quant à
nous le journal revient lundi avec
florane parfait il sera question au
cours de la semaine des commémorations
du 11 novembre qui marque l armistice de
1918 certaines communes vont dévoiler
les noms de nouveaux poilus retrouvé
grâce aux dernières recherches
généalogiques et puis également toutes
les informations cette semaine vous les
aurez sur le festival du film
documentaire à saint quentin qui se
déroulent du 12 au 15 novembre
exposition rencontres ateliers et bien
sûr projection à travers toute
l'agglomération pour l'ouverture du
festival
vous découvrirez demain réalisé par
cyril dion et mélanie laurent des
réalisateurs qui seront d'ailleurs
présents pour échanger avec le public
c'est à 21h à l'ugc le 12 novembre
en attendant une idée pour occuper votre
week end pourquoi ne pas skier dans les
yvelines puisqu'il ya maintenant de la
neige aux clayes-sous-bois le centre
commercial one nation paris prend des
airs de station de ski jusqu'à dimanche
prochain une rampe de ski de huit mètres
de haut a été installé à l'intérieur du
centre c'est une première en europe
un espace luge ans les enfants a
également été créé en parallèle de ses
activités
six nouvelles boutiques dont 3
spécialisé dans les sports d'hiver juste
ouvert leurs portes objectif pour la
direction de ce centre commercial le
redynamiser deux ans après son ouverture
on écoute philippe catteau c'est le
président de quatrinvest le propriétaire
l'objectif c'est d'apporter du monde en
plus de faire connaître aussi à des gens
qui ne connaîtraient pas forcément par
le simple hack soma mais qui peuvent
nous connaître aussi maintenant par des
activités par le ski par le sport
d'hiver ou et on trouvera d'autres on
fera d'autres déclinaisons autour de ces
thèmes donc des thèmes de la vie des
familles pour faire connaître le centre
plus rapidement dans l'ensemble de la
région parisienne jusqu'à paris
évidemment et c'est quand on regarde sur
une fréquentation sur la semaine
dernière par exemple keita semaine de
vacances évidemment on peut imaginer que
ça a mené entre 3 et 4000 clients
supplémentaires qui seraient peut-être
venue la semaine suivante un mets qui
ont profité de la traction la semaine
dernière et comme on peut le remarquer
en ce moment ça n'arrête pas pas dire la
luge est utilisé en permanence
on a des jeunes qui sont en permanence
des jeunes et des moins jeunes
d'ailleurs et pour le programme complet
de vos loisirs à suivre sur tv fils de
7,8 week end présentée par mélanie
poquet excellente fin de semaine
vous